foreign
what I actually want to think about is
not any of those things but about
whether or not female snakes experience
sexual pleasure
wow all right I didn't see that coming
but no I didn't yeah no
um
I guess you just leave it there
well it depends do you know the answer
there's some new research out oh that's
actually good was it a model that
decided that they don't experience
pleasure because the model told them
that they didn't experience pleasure
it's not that that's right well okay so
I'm actually I'm gonna I'm gonna not
say yet exactly what it is I will I will
say just a little bit first about
phylogeny and about
um character Evolution which sounds you
know we start with
female sexual pleasure we're going to
character Evolution what the hell
um snakes are lizards uh which usually
even phylogenesis to study snakes uh or
Lizards will when they're talking about
the group that includes snakes will say
lizards and snakes even though snakes
are lizards so together the lizards and
the snakes are the squamates the
squamada
and um the squamata have as every good
clay monophyletic clay that is there is
there is a point in time when that clade
originated and it is Diversified
radically and so that clade is
monophyletic it includes all of its
descendants of that first uh of that
first Proto squamate and there are
characters that is in normal parlance
you would say characteristics although
evolutionary biologists say characters
there are characters that diagnose the
clade even though you members of that
clade could then lose those characters
and that doesn't mean that they lose
their representation in the clay
diagnose doesn't mean that the clade is
sick
um well for so so things that you would
recognize would be that mammals have as
these diagnostic characters
synapomorphies in the technical language
of evolutionary biology have for
instance mammary glands and
um but not
um yeah mammary glands but not nipples
because the monitoriums the echidnas and
the Platypus you ain't a kidney at the
base of the mammal tree actually don't
have nipples but they don't have mammary
glands and fur is a diagnostic
characteristic and that you know you can
you can lose your fur as we have and you
remain a mammal but it was a character
that diagnosed
um the origin of of the clade and so um
a synapomorph if he had diagnosed a
shared derived character of squirmates
which is again lizards and six is having
hemipins which is two reversible
pins which is really how it's pronounced
I would have said penises but um as a
herpetologist I just say someone who
studies the creepy crawlies that include
the amphibians and reptiles
um I know that you're supposed to
pronounce it how many pins so for those
of you tuning in late Heather has not
had a stroke she's just teaching you how
to speak about the phylogeny of snakes
and lizards well I also think it's super
amusing to start with uh sexual pleasure
in female snakes and then go immediately
into the really dry stuff oh don't be a
beacon
which are not
they are not lizards but lizard no the
scissors their sister tuatar is because
wrinklesophilians are I believe sister
to squamous if I remember correctly they
yes they're not sister to lizards oh I
guess I guess they are yes because
lizards include snakes got it I've
caught up now I've had my stroke
but which is these shared two uh
reversible meaning they can they can be
tucked into the body and they come out
um penises
um peons all right I think it's peens
actually
um that males have on every male
squamate and they're used alternatively
during successive mating so if you've
ever seen snakes mate which like I
recommended actually it's kind of
interesting lizards too
um they they go at it from the side and
so like lizards will like wrap wrap
themselves around each other and if you
are able to watch them long enough if
they don't mind you watching them and
you follow them because this is what
herpetologists do in the field sometimes
you will see that it's the same pair or
even of just the same male you see him
made another time
um he will he will use his other penis
he will use the other side
so there's a lot of diversity across
squamates that is again lizards and
snakes in size in shape other
characteristics like some of them are
spiny some of those spines but not all
of them and
this has all been known for a long time
um I actually didn't look up how long
how many peans have been understood to
be the one of the diagnostic
characteristics of squamous but it's
been a long time and hat tip here to our
friend
um from from grad school Jennifer OST
who pointed me to this new research and
she in turn hat tipped her and my
graduate advisor Arnold cluge
because apparently and I was never
somehow I missed out on his soliloquies
about how all the research into
hemipines
um always avoided talking about the
um the the compatible part in females
which would be it's not pronounced
hemichitrises is it's hemi-clitaris I
guess okay
so here we are here we go
um apparently Kluge my graduate advisor
has been arguing for decades that know
what female snakes have is not just
underdeveloped hemipines thank you very
much
which of course because herpetology even
more than many fields within biology was
very dominated by men for a very long
time and because female genitalia in
general is considered like oh do we have
to I don't know and it's a little less
obvious and all of this to the degree
that anything was ever noticed in female
snakes
it was usually kind of like okay that's
just underdeveloped me there's nothing
to see there let's move along
and so you know hats off to clergy for
you know well before his time being like
no I don't think so I think there's
something there there well wait a second
do we have any idea how many parties
clergy ruined by mentioning this
I suspect having been at only a very few
parties that clingy was at that he was
the life of many yes I actually think
that he was the life of many parties and
that this probably caused an awkward
silence of maybe 30 seconds to a minute
and a half and then people would move
right along on the other hand you invite
uh invite Arnold clergy to a party you
probably know what you're getting
yourself into yeah you did it to
yourself pretty much you did it to
yourself okay so I'm just going to read
a couple things from this fabulous new
paper yeah this is published in uh the
proceedings of the Royal Society
uh first evidence of hemichitary is in
snakes uh from out of University of
Adelaide and Mount Holyoke and actually
University of Michigan Museum of zoology
which was of course where
um where
Jennifer and I were working with clukey
and and he wasn't on your committee but
he wouldn't you were also his his
student yep uh so the very first
sentence of the abstract of this paper
female genitalia are conspicuously
overlooked in comparison to their male
counterparts limiting our understanding
of sexual reproduction across vertebrate
lineages I would say they are
inconspicuously overlooked conspicuously
are like well conspicuous to some people
um the overlooking is conspicuous yeah
yes yeah exactly so later in the
abstract histology of the hemichliteris
and Australian death adders a campofis
antarcticus showed erectile tissue and
strands and bundles of nerves but no
spines as is found in male hemipins
these histological features suggest the
snake hemichitaries have functional
significance in mating and definitively
show that the hemic
hemichitaries are not underdeveloped
hemipines or set glands which have been
erroneously indicated in other studies
so first off just notice
the care and the rigor of the scientific
argument here
's what hemipines have here's what we
are finding in the death actors I love
what they use death they actually use
nine species but they went deep on the
death adders
um that's just so that they would have a
story yeah that's like that's like
studying like in on the face of El
Capitan right yeah I know I mean I think
this do it in Death matters you know the
first author is at the University of
Adelaide so
um although everyone else is that I
don't know there's two authors in
Australia
um
but they said okay so the the existing
hypotheses are it's just um scent glands
or it's underdeveloped hemipines if it
was underdeveloped hemipines you would
expect to see the same structures in
hemipines but less so and what they're
saying is now we did the dissections we
did the histology no no and no it's
they're they're it's different it is
presumably homologous
um the the hemichitaries in the female
Death headers adders and the hemipines
in the male death adders but one is not
just a like a half-assed version of the
other sorry no and this is the story of
research on female sexuality in general
not just in humans but in
snakes snakes as well so genitalia are
some of the fastest following
characteristics of amniotes with
internal fertilization so that
don't get me started on that but that's
fascinating because sexual selection
drives rapid Evolution because sexual
selection drives rapid Evolution but
specifically the question of internal
fertilization so
um so because the shape of the
structures then is relevant to the
sexual selection
yes that's that's
so the piece that I would love to be
talking about but I won't do here for
fear of losing more of our audience
is the conditions under which internal
fertilization versus external
fertilization evolve and what happens
when you have uh you know once you have
internal fertilization live birth versus
egg birth versus OVO Viva parity which
is like you have eggs inside your body
that then hatch so that you give birth
to something live but there wasn't any
Plus on toe fetal transfer of of
nutrients or resources along the way all
of these are fascinating actually snakes
make a an excellent system for looking
at the diversity of
um of within internal fertilization of
those types of types of birth
variation in clitoris morphology has
been linked to different degrees of
sexual arousal that could lead to
increased reproductive Fitness by
enticing females to copulate or forming
social bonds so this is the authors in
the introduction way of saying guess
what guys this actually matters like
this this is relevant it is interesting
and it does matter if you think you're
interested in sexual selection
Evolution at all really Behavior social
bonding all of these things
and then they say again even when
hemichitaries are described in lizards
these have been hypothesized to provide
a stimulatory role for the male during
intro mission right so to the degree
that there are like
potent you know tissues in female
genitals that could provide pleasure no
it's probably just to provide the male
pleasure like this is literally what's
in the literature well it also implies
it's a very long movie if there's an
information
so I will say you know this already
um
intro mission is different from
intermission ah okay
um okay uh just a couple more things
here
um unlike lizard Hemi clitories all
snake Hemi clitories examine lacked
spines sulcus spermaticus and retractor
muscles and could not be inverted by
manual manipulation suggesting that
something different interesting is going
on going on in snakes and I think
there's one more thing I don't need to
show the good reason detail
um
the presence of erectile bodies with
blood cells suggests that the
hemichitaries engorge with blood while
the presence of abundant nerve bundle
suggests that their stimulation May
provide sensory feedback to the females
so um maybe that's that's all I'll share
from the paper right now you can't of
course
um interview steaks and ask them about
their choice of Partners or whether or
not they're choosing to engage now
because they're sexually aroused but you
also can't do the kinds of things that
you would do in even other mammals and
look at you know basically measure
emotion in the same way you can't you
know you can't look you can't do the
same kind of analyzes so especially if
you've chosen to do it in death adders
would be dangerous can I just have never
mind it's you just know about your
business
um
but so they've done
they've done exactly the work that you
would you would want to have done if you
were interested in whether or not female
snakes experience sexual pleasure which
is okay there's actually structures here
and no they're not just kind of halfway
to what the males have they're actually
distinct structures and they both have
erectile capability and abundant nerve
bundles and they seem to do the same
thing that clitoris apparently is the
plural do in all the other species that
have them and yes they did it in death
adders and eight other species of things
okay but so I mean this is the nature of
science right because each study reveals
the next question that you want to
answer but it sounds like they did not
answer the question all right you've got
snakes with Hemi clitor eye but they
don't say what fraction of male snakes
are aware that female snakes have heavy
clitorized yes yes the male snakes are
continuing the story that uh to the
degree that the female Hemi clitor
series are there at all it's just to
help the males feel better about
themselves right and only the toxic male
snakes are saying that the the male
snakes are presumably also possessed of
the idea that each individual is the
best one that their female snake has
ever had that's right and obviously this
conversation is making our female
Labrador really unhappy I think she just
has to sneeze
[Music]
foreign